jean-joseph malidor bonjour oui bonjour
monsieur ripois vous êtes conseiller
municipal de l'opposition dont
l'opposition au morne rouge vous avait
63 ans
c'est la troisième fois que vous
présenter aux municipales et vous allez
conduire la liste union pour le réveil
pelléas et bien ça toute la famille
qu'est ce qui vous motive aujourd'hui à
bord une fois parce que c'est quand même
la troisième candidature
écoutez déjà je veux remercier de
m'inviter jeu seul bien sûr les les pdm
et bien sûr la martinique qui nous
écoutent
alors si je fais un peu d'histoire parce
qu'en fait ils feront faire un peu 1983
c'est d'abord la découverte du virus du
vih c'est le débarquement des américains
à grenade
c'est je dirais alors je vous rappelle
que vous avez cinq minutes a commis cinq
minutes mais sert victoire de noah mais
c'est aussi l'avènement d' l'élection
depuis à petit c'est au siècle dernier
puis à petit et julie c'est un couple
qui a géré la commune certainement bon
citoyen mais le monde a évolué vous
pensez quoi qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire par là c'est que sa commune relève
d'un autre temps que cette gestion
relève d'un autre temps que madame jenny
dulys réseau j'ai fait ce parallèle tout
simplement pour montrer que c'est au
siècle dernier que tous ces événements
se sont produits et pour dire que le
monde a changé les méthodes ont changé
l'évolution des gens les gens les envies
des gens ont changé et que lille le mont
rose n'a pas songé alors à ben écoutez
comme le mont rose ne pas entrer dans le
21e siècle
je pense que le monde rouge a oublié
d'être dans le 21e siècle puisque quand
on regarde en investissement les dix
dernières années il n'y a eu aucun
investissement
mais quand je dis que le monde a changé
que les besoins changé mais surtout que
les méthodes ont changé
ah ben il se trouve que le monde aussi
envie de changer et c'est bien pour cela
pour ma part je suis convaincu que le
changement est nécessaire hommes en
rouge
et pour preuve c'est que je me base sur
les élections précédentes et les
résultat m'encourage à continuer
et puis d'autre part je crois que j'ai
une responsabilité responsabilité de
conduire une équipe qui a envie de
changement et surtout un devoir
vis-à-vis de ses 900 électeurs les
dernières sélections
qu'est ce qui fait qu est ce qui vous
fait penser qu'aujourd'hui ça peut être
être l'homme du mouvement aujourd'hui
que savent que c'est votre heure qu'est
ce qui vous fait penser ça vous sur le
terrain vous percevez quelque chose je
viens de vous le dire je crois que les
choses ont changé et les choses ne sont
pas restés comme on est jamais venue est
ce que vous vous pensez vais quelque
chose vous vous dire oui c'est bon bon
bon parce que c'était quand même face à
madame petit face à jenny dulys petit
bain on peut se dire que je sais que ça
va se livrer jusqu'en face de quelqu'un
qui est là depuis trente sept ans et qui
arrive est à cours d'idée depuis design
ya eu aucun investissement mango
structurants il y à une dérive dans la
gestion communale
et ça je t'en parler la dérive qu'est ce
que vous entendez en parlant de dérive
de la gestion communale
ben quand je vous dis tout simplement
que les méthodes ont changé à l'époque
on pouvait subventionner des biens à
110% aujourd'hui il faut de vrais plans
de financement il faut une véritable
gestion des affaires communales
il faut une véritable rigueur dans le
contrôle des des structures qui
dépendent de la municipalité je parlais
de la caisse des écoles je parlais du
sport je veux parler éventuellement même
de la gestion des bâtiments communaux
qui ne sont pas entretenus qui ne sont
pas assurés qu'ils n'ont pas aujourd'hui
de commissions de sécurité mais qui ne
sont même pas rentable alors on se
gargarise de dire qu'ils sont
surdimensionnés être surdimensionnés
c'est une preuve de manque de gestion
des voyeurs de gestion on ne vous dit
pas quand vous avez besoin d'une voiture
pour deux personnes vous n'achetez pas
encore de vingt-et-une place donc ces
salles pour les membres
alors qu'elle sous quels sont vos
quelles sont les grandes lignes de votre
programme
sur quoi vous allez axé votre propre
venais de me dire que j'ai cinq minutes
donc je ne pouvais pas tout abordé 2 2
ou 3 j'aborde un début d'abord de la
gestion communale
là je suis en train de vous dire que il
ya trop de dépenses d'apparat le beau
certes mais les quartiers sont délaissés
je vous parlerai aussi de gestion
hasardeuse
je vous parlerai de manque de rigueur
dans le contrôle je viens de vous le
dire dans le contrôle des recettes
savez vous par exemple que le millennium
au morne-rouge que l'on vante ne
rapporte que 4700 euros par an c'est
extrêmement désagréable et ensuite une
gestion du personnel qu'il faudra gérer
pendant un exemple montrouge 170
salariés 130 non titulaires mais en même
temps on passe des contrats pour faire
des menus des menus projets comme le
lavage de murs comme si les 130 salariés
qui sont non titulaires ne pouvait pas
faire le lavage des meilleurs du monde
rouge voilà quelques exemples que je
pourrais vous dire et puis vous
démontrer que 15% du budget
d'investissements par an c'est bien la
preuve que nous avons une situation
financière tendue et cette situation
financière tendue
et justement due à cette mauvaise
gestion entre le personnel et les
marchés que l'on veut passer et
quelquefois avec ses propos ami joseph
mali dont je voulais mieux vous remet
ainsi déjà terminée c'est terminé j'ai
pas le temps de vous parler de quelque
chose
[Musique]